hey Denzel come over here come over here
come here come here really Chris
that's your Denzel impression that's not
very good man I don't know if that's
gonna work uh uh your mark Wolverton
present just as bad I'm really sorry you
guys had to deal with my impressions on
a regular basis - guns stars Denzel
Washington mark wahlberg paula patton
bill paxton and james marsden this movie
comes from the director of contraband so
him and wahlberg are teaming up again
and we're contraband was a little more
straightforward this is more of an
action comedy in this movie we have two
guys who were actually both undercover
trying to pin a bank robbery on the
other guy and use the other person to
get closer to this big stash of money to
be able to make a good score for the DEA
and the Navy respectively and when the
money turns out to be way more money
than they thought it was going to be and
they both realize they're actually good
guys a whole bunch of people suddenly
want this money and now we have our
movie I wasn't really looking forward to
two guns simply because of the director
I thought contraband was kind of mad but
it didn't really seem like a summer
movie to me it seemed kind of like a
February or March type movie and it
still feels that way after seeing it but
I can't say that it was a little bit
better than I thought it was going to be
by far the best part of this movie is
the chemistry between Denzel Washington
and Mark Wahlberg these guys work great
together
they're hilarious together this is
actually a really funny movie especially
because a Mark Wahlberg's character he's
actually pretty hilarious in this movie
he has some of the best jokes in the
entire movie in fact one joke they had
the audience in my theater including
myself roaring like into the next scene
like 10-15 seconds into the next scene
no one knew what anyone was saying in
that scene because everyone was laughing
and what he does at the end of this one
scene he was really funny in this movie
and I liked his character because he was
self-aware he wasn't just being stupid
to be stupid for screenplays sake like
hey Mark Wahlberg tells stupid joke like
his character understood that he's kind
of an idiot and he played off that and I
really like that about this movie Denzel
is always good I have always liked that
man he's very good in the movie but he
doesn't really do anything challenging
for him as an actor he does have some
great scenes he's pretty funny in the
movie himself and his chemistry like I
said with Mark Wahlberg is really good
also Bill Paxton is pretty entertaining
in this movie as a villain he comes in
and there's one guy in my theater who
for some reason felt the need to go Bill
Paxton
and I don't know why you did that but I
guess I kind of felt the same way every
time I see Bill Paxton I just
immediately think of that scene in
aliens where Lance Henriksen points at
that gas that's coming up and says yeah
that's gonna blow up pretty soon we're
all gonna die oh that's great man
that's great
Oh game over man game over he's
entertaining in this movie as this
villain who just wants that money very
badly
Paula Patton is also in the movie and
dear Lord Almighty is really really hot
in this movie I mean like every other
scene my mouth kind of went she's got a
great scene in this movie let me just
say yes James Morrison's character I
don't really want to say what he is or
what he does because his character is
also very twisty and turny and I don't
want to spoil what his character is but
I didn't really buy his character I'll
just put it that way he didn't have that
much screen time he didn't have that
much depth behind him at all
he didn't really understand what he was
doing some of the things he did and that
leads me to my biggest problem with this
movie and that is the screenplay this is
one of the most twisty turny movies of
the summer every other minute it seems
like there's a new twist of some kind
where a character is now at a different
place you're like oh what what no what
now it doesn't really make sense it's
very convoluted and scatterbrained and
as the movie goes on more twists more
turns and more twists and more turns and
more characters going this way and
characters going that way and you're
like where does this make sense and that
really is my biggest problem with the
movie the script is all over the place I
can't really sit down and say I'm going
to explain the plot of two guns 100% to
you from beginning to end because
there's just so much going on and a lot
of it doesn't feel like it makes sense
and if it does make sense on paper it
wasn't made clear to the viewer at least
for me if you're an audience member and
you're going to go to this movie you're
going to have fun with it
like I could tell my audience really dug
it there was a lot of funny parts the
characters worked well together there
were some entertaining action scenes
that weren't filmed horribly except for
one car chase which although wasn't
films terribly it just wasn't very
interesting until the end when the two
characters having the car chase got in a
fight and then it was pretty awesome but
because of the all-over-the-place script
and the story that isn't very remarkable
that seems to go in all different
directions I would say this is like an
excellent tip top rental like when this
comes out on red box or the PlayStation
Store or the Vudu app or
amazon instant rental or the video
on-demand or whatever is your choice of
rental i would say this is like the tip
tot rental ever you could rent this
movie and have a lot of fun i don't
really know if it's necessary to see it
in theaters it doesn't really feel like
a summer movie it's a fun action film
that you will probably enjoy on the
level of these characters are fun to
watch but if you really start thinking
about what's going on it doesn't really
make a lot of sense i'm gonna give two
guns a c+ so guys thanks as always for
watching very much what's your favorite
Denzel Washington movie or what's your
favorite Mark Wahlberg movie for me my
favorite Denzel movie I don't even
actually know that guy is like awesome
he is awesome Mark Wahlberg Oh totally
the happening definitely too happening
I'm kidding thanks a lot guys and if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]